welcome back to another episode of
vintage egyptologist
today i'm going to be talking about
historical fiction
now this was one of my favorite genres
of fiction when i was growing up and i
still love a good historical fiction
novel
but
what's really remarkable i mean this is
just amazing even though i've written a
book about the topic and i know this so
well
the ancient egyptians had historical
fiction
[Music]
the year is
1560 bce
this is what egyptologists call part of
the second intermediate period which is
roughly 1650-1550
this is the time between the middle
kingdom where you have a powerful
centralized kingship and the new kingdom
where again upper and lower egypt are
unified under a single pharaoh
however in 1560 there is a dynasty
ruling in the south this is the 17th
thieben dynasty so its capital is
ancient wasat
in the north you have the 15th dynasty
who were a series of hixos kings now
hixos is a greek term that comes from
ancient egyptian hakka khasit that means
ruler of the foreign lands
so the 15th dynasty are kings that are
not egyptian
and for any ancient egyptian to have
part of the nile valley ruled by a
foreign king is anathema
so the story that is set in this time
period so it was written around 1250 bce
but set in 1560 bce
and the modern title that we give it is
the corals of a pepe and secantera
a pepe is a hyxose king often spelled
out apophis in modern histories but this
is really misleading because apophis is
also the greek term that we tend to use
for the chaos serpent ah pep so a peppy
the hicksos king and ah pep the chaos
serpent sounds really similar to us but
it's actually spelled with two different
signs at the beginning in ancient
egyptian so it doesn't seem like that's
a comparison that they're making
now king sikkinenrah
is a king of the 17th dynasty and the
way this story begins is that a pepe and
cicanan raw are having a quarrel not in
terms of a fully fledged military
conflict that is yet to come between the
17th and 15th dynasties but instead
they're having a battle by
letter
so i'm going to read here from the
translation that i published in 2013 in
my book imagining the past historical
fiction in new kingdom egypt and this is
how the story starts
then it happened that the land of egypt
was in a state of pestilence with no
legitimate lord living prosperous and
healthy as king at that time
at the same time it happened that as for
king cannon raw he was the sovereign of
the southern city so that's the
reference to ancient wasset greek thebes
modern luxor
pestilence was in the city of rey that's
a reference to heliopolis because of
them
referencing here the hixos while the
ruler of pepe was in hootware and that
was the capital of the 15th hixos
dynasty
and the entire land was controlled for
him for a pepe
bearing their taxes the north as well
bearing all the good produce of the
delta so what this is telling us is that
a pepe the hicksos king is essentially
in economic control of egypt even though
sakananra is king in the south
then king a pepe
made set as lord this is seth the god of
chaos the god who fights with horus to
be king of egypt and he meaning our pepe
did not work for any other god who was
in this entire land except seth and he
built a temple of fine workmanship for
eternity beside the domain of king a
pepe
and he appeared each day in order to
make sacrifices doing it daily for set
while the officials carried wreaths
so what this is essentially saying is
that king appepi is not only
not a legitimate king of egypt but he's
committing a religious sin
by offering only to the god set and
doing so
as is done in the temple of reihorahti
at heliopolis so he's only worshipping
set and he's not worshipping him
properly
meanwhile and this is where the action
really starts a peppy desired to send an
offensive message to the king to canon
raw the sovereign of the southern city
now after many days following this
and unfortunately the text really breaks
up here
so the next part of the story is that a
pepe's message reaches luxor
and it says that his messenger was taken
into the presence of the sovereign of
the southern city so that's the candera
then one
king sikenera said to a pepe's messenger
quote
why have you been sent to the southern
city why have you reached me with these
journeys
then the messenger said to him it is
king a pepe who sends to you saying
quote
expel the hippopotami from the swamp
that is on the eastern waters of the
city
because they talking about the
hippopotami
do not allow that sleep come to me day
or night because their noise
is in my ear
then the sovereign of the southern city
was surprised for a long moment
being unable to respond to the messenger
of king a pepe and i think we're a
little surprised too right 500 miles
separates luxor from avarus wassets from
houthwarret so how are hippopotami 500
miles away keeping a pepe awake
and this is really the crux of the story
so we know that our peppy worship set
to the exclusion of all of the gods and
we know that he is in conflict with
sikenan raw but he sends this message
complaining of the noisiness of the
hippopotami and what i think is going on
here
because hippopotamus can be a
representation an animal manifestation
of the god set
that even though a pepe the foreign king
worships set
and even though he thinks set is on his
side set with these noisy hippopotami is
actually getting back at the
now
foreign
king
unfortunate that the one papyrus copy we
have of this story papyrus salier one
which is in the british museum
which was copied in year 10 of the reign
of mernepta by a scribe named pental
wear it seems to have had other things
on his mind by the time he gets to the
end of the story so it's rather broken
up and then it says that the sovereign
of the southern city so this is the
cunning again
has his officials summoned as well as
every commander and he repeated to them
every communication about which king a
pepe sent to him
and they were all together quiet for a
long time not knowing how to respond to
him good or bad
then king alpepi sent
and that's it the text breaks off but
the papyrus is not actually broken
instead what seems to happen is that
penta where it has copied enough of the
story that now he moves on to an
instruction of letter writing
so i think what penta warett is doing
is he's promoting
scribes he's saying that there are these
two kings who are quarreling
but what's most important are the
scribes that are writing the letters
back and forth the next part of the
british museum papyrus is a rather
boring manual of letter writing so i
think penta where it copied this
fascinating story the coral of a pepe
and san sakennenbra to get his scribal
students interested in what's going to
come next
so because we only have one copy of the
story and it doesn't preserve the ending
we don't know what happens we do not
know
whether in the story a pepe and the
canon raw actually have a pitched
military conflict or who gains the upper
hand
however we do know historically what
actually happened a pepe continued to be
king of the hixos
until the reign of komoza another
seventeenth dynasty king king sukkanen
raw of thieves met a very different fate
we know from his mummy that was
discovered in the dear albari cashette
of royal mummies that he died in battle
and we know that because there's a
hixo's battle axe shaped
hole
in his skull as where as well as a
number of other injuries
so in the end
raw died fighting the hyxos almost
certainly king of pepe but through the
medium of historical fiction the
egyptians were able to recast this
complex time in their history as a
narrative of victory and triumph and
ultimately the centrality of scribes and
literacy in ancient egypt and if the
readers of the story did not know a
little bit about history it simply
wouldn't have been fun to read just like
historical fiction today
so now you've heard all that we have of
the story of the equals of a pepe and
secanero one of the most important works
of ancient egyptian historical fiction
in future episodes i'm going to
introduce you to three additional
stories
next up is the capture of joppa and
ancient egyptian soldiers hiding in
baskets to capture the city thank you
for tuning in please don't forget to
subscribe and there are lots of notes
below if you want to learn more about
these stories
[Music]
okay